on dit souvent que la région centre est
considéré comme le jardin de la france à
juste titre le val de loire lance la
troisième édition des nouvelles
renaissance un festival qui met à
l'honneur la créativité et l'art de
vivre et comme à chaque rendez-vous les
lieux les plus emblématiques participent
présentation du programme à chaumont sur
loire en présence de deux invités de
prestige stéphane bern et le jardinier
le plus célèbre de france alain baraton
reportage de samuel collant
en vert bleu ou jaune pour l'ouverture
de cette nouvelle saison quelle que soit
la couleur ou la fleur la région brille
de mille feux et au milieu coule un
fleuve le parrain de l'édition 2022
alain baraton est sous le charme il est
vrai que la loi ne s'est pas contenté de
donner vie à cette région elle la
destinait on le voit bien dans ses
méandres quelqu'un qu'elle produit à
certains lieux donc vraiment la loire
c'est le premier jardinier de la région
c'est une beau théâtre à tomber à la
renverse 1 500 événements recensés pour
l'instant tous les grands sites sont
labellisés chaumont chambord villandry
valmer ou leurs rivaux et après 2019 et
les 500 ans de la renaissance stéphane
bern mais à nouveau lui aussi sa pierre
à l'édifice cette année j'essaie
d'apporter simplement ma notoriété ou le
service de cette région que j'aime on
travaille tous dans le même sens c'est
pour faire aimer notre région développer
le tourisme aussi un tourisme
intelligent un tourisme par exemple avec
l'avé losséni un tourisme écologique
respect aussi la la biodiversité le
jardin de la france l'expression prend
autant de formes que de lieux du potager
nourricier au parterre formelle des
jardins à la française
un événement qui se veut populaire et
ouvert à tous les sites de la région
avec une campagne de communication
commune et un appel à projets cinq cent
mille euros mis sur la table pour
soutenir les propositions nous avons une
communication à l'échelle de la région
jardin de la france nous pouvons trouver
tous les événements les pique niques des
grand pique nique les expositions les
animations les colloques et puis il ya
au delà de ça un certain nombre de
projets qui ont eu besoin d'eux
bien et tous les rendez vous sont à
retrouver sur le site nouvelle
renaissance au pluriel point com